we adrift in space with zero on the
promise of rescue is more fun than it
sounds
if you find this recording don't feel
better at this just an old message
oxygen out tomorrow morning part of the
journey you see some people mean move on
better than us
not us
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie now that we've
gotten some Avengers and game trailers
it's time to talk about post credit
scene theories they're foreshadowing a
lot of character arcs coming to a close
in all the footage that we've seen so
far so you have people like Captain
America that just look so tired all they
want to do is just bring everyone back
there's so so pissed off about all the
people they lost so just a reminder that
there are several different types of
post credits scenes and mid credit
scenes that Marvel works into their
videos there are ones that pay off big
jokes that they set up during the film
like just funny ha-ha moments with the
characters from the movie like the
second Stan Lee cameo with the Watchers
and guardians of the galaxy vol 2 like
he'd already appeared it was just like a
funny tag as he continued telling them
about all his adventures in the other
Marvel post-credit scenes then they have
the teasers for big things that are
coming down the road like winking at
Thanos at the end of the very first
Avengers film usually those wind up
being specific to each franchise so
because we're talking about a big
Avengers movie it would tease what's
happening in future Avengers movies with
a villain or some big concept like the
idea that we're gonna have proliferation
of people with biological powers we're
still doing that Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite post-credit
scene on the video so we'll do this top
10 style currently guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 is the record holder
with most number of post credits and mid
credit scenes it has 5 so we'll see if
Avengers endgame beats that but starting
with number 10 the obvious original
Avengers swarm a moment the ones that
are still alive at the end of the film
have another swarm of style moment just
a funny way to take the edge off of any
potential big Avenger deaths because I
do expect at least one a list Avenger to
seemingly die although you know it's a
comic book movie so you always kind of
wonder how much that's gonna stick the
twist being though that instead of just
repeating the original shawarma moment
what they do is they pay off the joke
that they set up during infinity war
with everybody on the Avengers having a
flavor of Ben and Jerry's named after
them they all just eat each other's
flavor of Ben and Jerry's and I swore
off dairy but then Ben and Jerry's named
a flavor after me so stark raving
hazelnuts not Ben bit chalky how got
Hulk of burning fudge is our favorite
thing that was probably one of the
funniest jokes right before things got
real
crazy during infinity war number nine
expecting that there'll be some balanced
happy and sad moments during the end of
the movie like there'll be some sad
moments but they're also trying to end
on a happy note a post-credits scene
paying off a big joke from Iron Man and
Pepper Potts wedding between secondary
characters like we're talking teenage
Groot and spider-man or Stan Lee like
they do another Watchers style multiple
scenes with Stan Lee moment where he
appears a couple times during the film
as different characters like the bus
driver winds up at Tony Stark's wedding
for some reason I've already done a
couple videos based on some of the
deleted scenes from infinity war about
why I think they've Rashaad Iron Man and
Pepper Potts wedding being the way that
they wind up ending all these movies
because it's a really happy moment the
actors have been describing infinity war
and Avengers endgame is this really
grand Shakespeare even Josh Brolin who's
been performing Thanos in both of the
movies in most Shakespeare comedies wind
up ending in a wedding of some sort so
because they're teasing this big moment
at the beginning of infinity war it just
seems like they're gonna end on
something like that
number eight post-credit scenes with the
different teams that push them into
their next big movies whatever those
might be so like a moment with the
guardians of the galaxy with a return
Gamora Peter quill the rest of them
reunited family going back off into
whatever the adventure of guardians of
the galaxy three is going to be they're
currently saying that they're still
gonna use James Gunn's scripts so
whatever that movie was originally going
to be it's still gonna be that but
because spider-man far from home is
happening minutes after the end of
Avengers endgame you also have to like
have a moment where you set up what
that's going to be like this moment here
where Peter is helping with disaster
relief on behalf of Iron Man and Pepper
Potts doing all this PR work giving all
these donations to people that are
working on homeless shelters it just
implies there's gonna be even more
wanton destruction in New York City
during avengers endgame and this will be
part of the cleanup process number seven
a scene with the watchers again in a
direct continuation of The Watcher
scenes during guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 the things that the Avengers in
Thanos have done with the Infinity
stones and the Infinity Gauntlet are too
big for the Watchers not to be present
for most of it to begin with even if
it's just another moment with Stan Lee
continuing to report to them recapping
the events of infinity war in Avengers
end game well first I was a bus driver
and
was all these different things during
this second movie number six you have to
have a scene with Black Panther and the
original Avengers that are still alive
where they formally asked him to join
the Avengers and henceforth take a
leadership role and you know funny
moment haha ask him to help foot the
bill for all their expensive toys maybe
a little bit of winking at loaning them
Sheree in a load of vibranium every once
in a while and he just kind of chuckles
like haha we'll see about that
whatever you think about the character
because his movie was so big there's no
way that he is not one of the focal
points of the Avengers during phase four
at some point but also number five a
similar moment with Captain Marvel with
them doing the same thing the surviving
original Avengers formally asking her to
join the Avengers and take on a
leadership role with the idea of Nick
Fury teasing sword from the comics a
more space-based defense agency dealing
with threats before they actually make
it to planet Earth's surface before
getting involved like shield is more of
a ground-based organization for the most
part the last couple of years Captain
Marvel has been focused with
extraterrestrial threats in outer space
so she lives in a space station that
orbits planet Earth and deals with like
really big cosmic threats before they
make it to Planet Earth number four a
scene with Thor either constructing or
working at new Asgard in Norway where
they set up during thor ragnarok they
may already have a small moment like
this during avengers endgame because we
know that Valkyrie is actually gonna
have a cameo during the actual movie not
just a post-credits scene she'll
actually be in the movie for a little
while but at the end of thor ragnarok in
the beginning of Avengers infinity war
she in Cork escaped the Asgardian ship
before Thanos arrived with about 25% of
the Asgardians that they had taken from
a scarred so we just stands to reason
that if they didn't go to another planet
they probably went to where new Asgard
is and started to build it while Thor
has been busy with all this infinity war
business so either he goes back to that
location and starts building it during a
post-credits scene or there's a moment
like that during the movie where they
addressed that because a little time has
gone by since the snap number three a
multiverse based scene teasing very
different very cool comic book moments
with characters in other realities like
teasing other major threats for future
movies a la Dormammu expecting that the
Infinity stones are probably gonna be
scattered or destroyed at the end of the
movie so if you haven't read a lot of
Marvel's
big comic book events that involve the
Infinity stones typically what happens
is is when the Avengers or someone else
uses them in something really crazy
happens they wind up scattering or they
wind up shattering and they become
ineffective so because Kevin Feige is
teasing that phase four is gonna be so
vastly different from the way the first
22 films felt the Infinity stones have
been the thing since Marvel phase 1 so
we just stands to reason that they're
going to quote-unquote retire that in
the way you do that is they either
scatter the gems or you shatter them so
that it won't be useful in phase 4
nobody will be able to go find one and
start using it again so really important
moment to pay off that means that the
time stone is no longer a deterrent to
Dormammu that was the whole thing
Dormammu I've come to bargain that was
the reason why he agreed to stay away
from Planet Earth and if that goes away
then that means the earth is easy
pickings for Dormammu to come back and
get his revenge getting into more phase
4 stuff too you have to have a scene
teasing the concept of the Eternals and
more Celestials as part of their story
where as far we've only really dealt
with in the guardians of the galaxy
movies we get a little bit of celestial
stuff like Peter quill was part
celestial with crazy powers for a little
while now he still has celestial DNA
inside him but he doesn't have the
special powers because ego the Living
Planet status to be determined seems
like he's dead you also need to have a
moment paying reference to some of the
consequences of the Avengers messing
with reality in the quantum realm right
now the quantum realm is sort of a JJ
Abrams mystery box type of story device
like they could do anything they want to
with it because it's the past of the
realities it's the path to biological
powers like the wasps past special
powers because her DNA has been altered
by quantum energy they could use it as
the basis for literally any type of
Marvel comic book story that you could
think of but number one they also have
to have a scene teasing the concept of
x-men heading into what will become
Avengers 5 so obviously you're a big
Avengers 5 post-credit scene because
they all do that at the end of the
Avengers movies this is what we're gonna
be dealing with in the next big one but
here's the thing because the x-men Fox
Disney deal won't close till the summer
they can't say the word x-men or a
mutant or anything like that what
they'll have to do is just tease the
idea that there's a proliferation of
people with spell
abilities popping up all over the world
and Nick Fury in some of the other
Avengers will just keep an eye on it
quote unquote until it becomes more
serious than a couple movies down the
road when we get to our next big
Avengers film quote unquote
it will get more serious and those
people that have popped up will wind up
being big x-men characters so that's
about as close as they could get without
saying yeah x-men are definitely coming
in our next couple of films without
jumping the gun or literally saying it
or showing them on screen there are a
lot of other big concepts that they
could also tease and post credits scenes
you have the idea of The Young Avengers
Kevin Feige said that they're developing
a movie with that because Kang the
Conqueror is one of their big villains
that could be a time travel based
franchise and we've started to do more
time travel in the MCU
but between Celestials eternals big
future villains in the quantum realm
you just have to address some of those
big moments so let me know in the
comments what are your picks
for what the post-credits scenes are
during avengers endgame and I'm talking
about mid credits and post credits for
those of you asking about that three
hour runtime rumor there was a website
that was reporting that Avengers endgame
is going to be three hours it is not
going to be three hours there is no way
the Disney's gonna let the Russos
release a three hour movie what they'll
probably do is they'll just cut it down
til it's a little bit longer than
Avengers infinity war that was 2 hours
and 29 minutes so Avengers and game will
still probably be the longest Marvel
film ever and just like a little over
two and a half hours but I'm sure that
when they released the blu-ray there'll
be some crazy double box set with
infinity war and Avengers end game and
they'll release a bunch of extra footage
and deleted scenes so that's where you
get your Marvel movie that's longer than
three hours but it's because of all the
extra bonus features that they'll
probably wind up putting on that there
will be a new Avengers end game trailer
coming with Captain Marvel so of course
I'll do a video for it when it drops
leave your requests in the comments
below I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post new Marvel click here to rewatch
the avengers endgame trailer a billion
more times and all my Easter eggs and
click here for the spider-man far from
home trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]